[Musik]
bvb-star mats hummels und seine ehefrau
cathy haben das saisonende mit einem
urlaub am tegernsee gefeiert das paar
versorgt die fans regelmäßig mit
einblicken neben baden und lesen stehen
auch sportliche aktivitäten wie stand up
paddling und mountainbiken auf dem plan
gerade bei letzterem hat kathi eine
lektion gelernt
nächstes mal besser nicht mit langen
platter hosen und flipflops losfahren
ich möchte aber trotzdem einfach mal so
ein bisschen aus meinem haus raus aus
den eigenen vier wänden und den titeln
sind 57 von münchen und dann haben wir
gedacht machen wir es uns da schön und
ich habe bayern würde ich mal sagen auf
eine ganz neue art und weise wieder
kennengelernt noch mehr lieben gelernt
und es ist wirklich krass was für schöne
orte wir hier in deutschland tragen
deswegen ja ins auto gesetzt 50 minuten
gefahren und dann war mir schon im
urlaub ihr habt ganz ganz viele fotos
geteilt sowohl du als auch gemacht was
habt ihr alles so gemacht für die die
fotos nicht gesehen haben
du willst jetzt auch ich bin auf alles
aus also ich habe auch ganz viele bikini
bilder gesehen
ach so ja die kommen da er von mir
genommen waren bauten beiden wir haben
einfach entspannt stand up paddle wir
sind viel spazieren gegangen
wir haben sehr lecker gegessen und ich
habe mich ein bisschen besonders in
braun geworden ich war nämlich wirklich
so weiß wie die wand das sogar schon
eine ziemlich gesagt haben bitte jetzt
gehst endlich mal im sommer und da gar
nichts sagen sondern ich mich und dann
habe ich versucht einfach auch ein
bisschen seitenstreifen ein bisschen
avatar zu arbeiten und einfach von den
familien zeit verbringen quality time
seele baumeln lassen und haben
ich würde sagen wir schaffen teilt wenn
die sommerpause ist oder winterpause ist
was sonst funktioniert es ja gar nicht
und ich bin doch man muss jetzt nicht
sagen wir machen elendig lange urlaub
wichtig ist einfach dass man zeit
miteinander verbringen und qualität rein
dass man nicht bewusst auch eben die
zeit nimmt und jetzt muss man halt auch
sagen erzählt und ungewohnter ist es
ganz einfach ein bisschen schwierig
[Musik]